at a Christmas market in Brussels a
peaceful mood children have come with
their classmates colleagues and families
are here to enjoy their first day of
winter vacation word any other day but
this one they'd be in high spirits but
many say their thoughts are with the
victims of Berlin's truck attack and
they refuse to stay away Mona mean
sumitomo [ __ ] Rockies Joseon Venegas my
friend and I were debating whether to
come here or not and then we decided yes
we will we'll come out of solidarity and
in memory of the dead and injured in
Berlin oh so Odyssey day kyosho victim
for montessori Davide we may have to
show solidarity but this terrorism makes
me furious I'm French we had this a nice
now Berlin it makes me so angry the box
it sits at Aslam Aslam yep olivia d'abo
man of course we're thinking about what
happened but for us it's important to
keep going and live our lives whatever
happens and there's plenty of security
staff everywhere oye bakwas also
military the pretty sit on every among
EU politicians more solidarity flags in
the government quarter are all at
half-staff the day began with a minute
of silence earlier the President of the
European Commission jean-claude yanka
expressed his condolences in a written
statement hours after the attack my
thoughts he said are with the families
of all the dead and wounded in Berlin
the mayor of Brussels held a news
conference to express his sympathy to
Berliners he offered his reflections
around his own experience of terrorism
yeah you don't I do partly first Paris
done Brussels and nice life is not the
same anymore couldn't we have to have
heightened security and keep stepping it
up to adapt to every you threat en
cuando semanas a shock phone is adopted
the man in charge of that is Olivier
miss the attack in Nice last July
motivated him to introduce new security
measures to guard against vehicles that
could be used as weapons of
Jack 49 contender block own sake for
internet me we have about 40 cement
blocks weighing a ton and a half each
don't prevention le priligy leafy good
look they can prevent a heavy vehicle
from ramming a particular area no
salvation what tilde Percy besides
expressing their solidarity politicians
in Brussels also stress that big cities
such as brussels and berlin can never be
completely free of danger there's no
such thing as a no risk space anymore